hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and in this video i will be
explaining the origins and backstory
of every single known titan shifter
in the attack on titan world from the
very first titan
emir fritz who lived nearly 2 000 years
ago
to all of the current titan shifters
this video will teach you
everything you need to know about the
origins of these
titan users there is a ton of exciting
information to dive into
and this video took a ton of work but
it was highly requested and since a
youtuber is nothing without his audience
it is my pleasure to do this for you
guys so if you enjoy videos like this
one and you want to see more in the
future
please slap that like button and leave a
comment
it really helps a lot and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you've been
watching our videos for a while but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't want to
miss future videos you really have to go
through the trouble
of subscribing hitting that bell and
then selecting the option that says
all finally this video will contain
attack on titan manga spoilers i'm using
all of the available information from
the manga so please proceed with caution
you have been warned first up let's talk
about the very first
titan the progenitor emir fritz
about 1820 years before the beginning of
the main attack on titan story
emir was a normal human girl whose
village was attacked by ancient
aldean soldiers emir and her people were
captured as slaves and they were all
forced to serve the ruthless king fritz
of
eldia presumably emir herself was not
ethnically aldian she was a slave
of the aldians one day someone opened
the gate to a pigpen
and let a bunch of pigs loose emir was
blamed for letting the pigs loose
and her punishment was to be hunted for
sport by the aldean soldiers
as she ran for her life from the cruel
soldiers
an injured emir came across a strange
ancient
looking tree there was an opening at the
bottom of the tree and emir tried to
hide inside of it
but when she entered the opening she
fell into some sort of sinkhole
filled with liquid just when it looked
like emir was about to drown
a strange spine-like creature attached
itself
to her in the next moment emir and that
creature fused
and that is when emir transformed into
the very
first titan her titan shifter was
absolutely enormous
easily dwarfing even the colossal titans
and this was the only known titan
shifter who embodied
all nine titan powers within one person
when he saw this
incredible power the king of eldia
changed his mind
about killing emir instead of killing
her he made her one of his wives
and used her to expand the aldian empire
emir went along with it and served the
king loyally
despite his cruelty thanks to emir's
titan form
the aldians were able to annihilate
their enemies including the ancient
marlians
and they were also able to build the
kind of large-scale infrastructure that
the other nations who didn't have titans
could only dream of and so thanks to the
power of emir's titan
the aldean empire became the dominant
power on the continent
eventually emir and king fritz had three
daughters
maria rose and sheena the three walls on
the island of paradise were actually
named
after these daughters thirteen years
after receiving the power of the titans
emir died
protecting the eldian king when an
assassin attempted to kill the king with
a spear
emir in her human form jumped out in
front of him
and was killed by the spear presumably
the spear pierced her heart and killed
her before she could use her titan power
to recover
or perhaps she no longer had the will to
live by that point
although that's just speculation after
the death of amir
king fritz ordered their three daughters
to eat the remains of their mother in
order to inherit the power of the titans
the ritual worked and it was repeated
multiple times in the coming generations
until the power of the titans was split
into nine distinct
titan shifters since emir died 13 years
after gaining the power of the titans
every subsequent titan shifter also
inherited this
curse of emir and each of them died 13
years after becoming a titan shifter
after her death some aspect of emir's
consciousness was transported to the
mysterious land of the paths
where she continues to serve the ldn
royal bloodline by molding titans for
her descendants
after the power of the titans was split
into nine different titan shifter powers
the founding titan in particular was
closely guarded by the fritz
royal family after many centuries of ldn
dominance over the continent
the 145th king of aldia named carl
fritz decided to abandon the continent
and create the world behind the walls on
the island of paradise
this took place about 100 years before
the events of the main attack on titan's
story carl
fritz decided to abandon the continent
and the aldean empire itself
because he was tired of the constant
conflicts and civil wars that plagued
the empire
not only were the other nations
suffering under ldn domination
but the various ld and noble families
were always fighting each other over the
control of the nine titan shifters
carl fritz was tired and ashamed of all
of it
so in collaboration with the tiber
family who controlled
the warhammer titan king fritz abandoned
most of the aldians on the continent
and took only a small fraction of them
to the island of paradise
once on the island he used the power of
the founding titan to create the three
walls which were formed using
thousands upon thousands of colossal
titans and he also manipulated the
memories of everyone on the island so
that they would think that they were the
last survivors
in a world that was overrun by mindless
monsters
known as the titans in order to further
conceal the truth and protect the royal
family
the name of the royal family was changed
to rhys and a fake king was placed on
the throne
carl fritz's motivation for abandoning
the continent and moving to the island
was a desire to live in peace
for as long as possible until the world
inevitably decided to punish the aldians
for everything their ancestors had done
over the past 2000 years king fritz even
created the vow of pacifism
a hereditary ideology that forced every
inheritor of the founding titan who
possessed royal blood to adopt a passive
stance to the outside world
including refusing to fight back even if
the island is attacked
after carl fritz the next founding titan
shifter that we are aware of is the
father of rod and yuri
reese we don't know his first name or
very much about him
but we do know that he inherited the vow
of pacifism from carl fritz
rod and yuri both knew that their father
had the power to free the humans from
their confinement behind the walls
and they knew that he could eliminate
the titans beyond the walls if he wanted
to
in fact they often pleaded with him to
do exactly
that but their father refused to act
he even had his son rod locked up after
he wouldn't take no for an
answer the founding titan power was
eventually passed down to yuri reese the
younger brother of rod
before becoming the founding titan yuri
had vowed to use that power to eliminate
the titan threat beyond the walls
and free humanity but after he actually
became the next founding titan
he also inherited the pacifist ideology
of carl fritz
and so just like his father before him
yuri refused to make any real changes
despite spending his entire childhood
begging his father to do
exactly that but yuri did turn out to be
more compassionate than his father in
one regard
after meeting kenny ackerman yuri
finally put a stop to the decades-long
persecution of the ackermann family
within the walls
and by the way although rodris
eventually becomes a titan as well
he turns into a gigantic abnormal titan
and not
into a titan shifter after the death of
yuri reese
the power of the founding titan was
inherited by the eldest daughter of
rodrice
freda who also happened to be the older
half-sister of historia
frida became the next founding titan at
the age of 15.
she was shown to be a kind and
compassionate person and we know that
she paid regular visits to her
half-sister historia
because historia was an illegitimate
child of rodris
she was seen as a liability by the
ruling elite on paradise
and as a result she had a very tough
childhood the only person who was nice
to historia was frida herself
although frida would use the power of
the founding titan to erase historia's
memories
after each of their meetings she did
this to protect historia from the
dangerous truth about her royal
origins like the other royal inheritors
of the founding titan
after carl fritz frida inherited the
valve pacifism when she refused
to protect the people of the island
following the fall of walmaria
grisha jaeger tracked her down and stole
the founding titan power away from her
killing her in the process the founding
titan power would eventually make its
way from grisha to aaron
but since the two of them don't have
royal blood the primary titan power that
they used was of course the attack titan
so now let's talk about all of the
attack
titan shifters the very first known
attack titan was
aaron krueger an aldian who was born in
marley
as we know marlei ruthlessly oppresses
its elden population
and when he was still just a child
krueger witnessed his parents being
burned
alive by marlene soldiers krueger's
father had been an
aldian rebel fighting against marlene
tyranny but his activities were
discovered by the marlene authorities
and he was burned to death
aaron krueger was hidden inside a closet
at that time and he watched it all
unfold
until eventually he was rescued by
friends of his father
at some point krueger found an aldean
doctor who was able to make
fake blood tests for him even though he
was an ethnic
aldian kruger used fake tests to portray
himself
as an ethnic marlian and on that basis
he was able to join the marland public
security forces
after successfully infiltrating the
merlion security forces
kruger became a spy for the ldn
restorationists
his code name among the restorationists
was the owl
and no one knew who he really was in
order to successfully play the role of a
devoted marlin officer
krueger had to take part in many
atrocities that were committed against
his
own people and this only steeled his
resolve
further krueger happened to be one of
the two marlin officers who caught
ayan grisha and his sister faye when
they snuck out of the liberio internment
zone
in order to see a blimp krueger beat
grisha as punishment for what he had
done
but he didn't kill him unfortunately
grisha's sister
faye was not so lucky the other marlene
officer who was there
gross who has a name that fits him
perfectly by the way
took fey with him and he had her killed
for fun
about two years after that incident
aaron krueger managed to take possession
of the attack
titan power after the adult grisha was
betrayed by his own son
zeke and taken to the island of paradise
to be transformed into a mindless titan
kruger saved grisha and killed gross
he then revealed his true identity took
out the marlan forces who had come to
the island
and transferred the power of the attack
titan on to grisha
grisha is the father of aaron and zeke
and the former holder of the attack
and founding titan powers like aaron
krueger
grisha was an aldian born in marley and
he lived
inside the liberia internment zone along
with his parents and younger sister faye
until she was ruthlessly murdered by the
marlin officer named gross
faye's murder occurred after grisha
convinced her to sneak out of liberio in
order to look at an airship
and this was strictly against the rules
so for the rest of his life grisha would
feel guilty about what happened to his
sister
the tragic death of his sister inspired
grisha to fight back
against marley even though grisha's
father urged him to keep his head down
and accept the punishment that the
aldians are now receiving for the sins
of their
ancestors krisha refused to accept that
the current generation of aldians should
suffer because of events that occurred
long before any of them were ever born
grisha eventually became a doctor
and he also joined an underground aldean
rebel movement known as the aldean
restorationists
the goal of the restorationists was to
destroy marlei
and bring back the glory of the aldian
empire
through the restorationists grisha met a
woman named dina fritz
an aldian with royal blood her ancestors
were members of the royal bloodline who
did not follow
king carl fritz to the island of
paradise grisha and dina fell in love
and they had a son named zeke when his
son was about 7 years old
grisha decided to place him in the
marland warrior candidate program
grisha was hoping that if zeke could
inherit one of the titan shifters
his royal blood would give him the
ability to become stronger than the
other titan shifters
and eventually zeke could be used to
capture the founding titan from the
island of parodies and use it to
liberate the aldians on the continent
however zeke betrayed his parents to the
marlene authorities
and many of the restorationists were
captured as a result
of this betrayal like so many aldians
before them
the restorationists including grisha and
his wife dina
were sentenced to be forcibly turned
into mindless titans
and let loose on the island of paradise
after all the other restorationists were
transformed into titans
including his wife grisha was suddenly
saved by aaron krueger
who revealed himself to be the owl
krueger killed gross and the other
merlin soldiers
he told grisha everything he knew about
the titans and he entrusted grisha with
an important
mission grisha had to inherit the attack
titan from kruger and use it to
infiltrate the walls and take back the
founding titan from the reese family
krueger also warned grisha about the
curse of emir
grisha accepted this mission took
possession of the attack titan power
and made the journey from the coast of
the island to the walls
he was eventually found wandering around
the walls outside of shiganshina
district by
keith shadis in order to avoid suspicion
from the islanders
grisha claimed to have amnesia although
he eventually admitted to remembering
his name and the fact that he was a
doctor
everyone simply assumed that grisha was
a local who lost his memories and
somehow ended up behind the walls
and so grisha was able to integrate into
the society on parodies
he also made a name for himself as an
excellent doctor
since he had knowledge of modern
medicine that no one else on the island
possessed
in time grisham met carla married her
and together they had a son
named aaron while pretending to be a
regular resident of shiganshina
grisha secretly searched for the
location of the royal family
and the current founding titan shifter
he eventually located them
but because he was happy with his life
on the island he initially didn't do
anything about it
nevertheless when walmaria fell and the
people of the island were attacked by
both the mindless titans and the marlan
titan shifters
grisha confronted frida and pleaded with
her to do something to protect the
innocent people of the island
when frieda refused grisha defeated her
in a titan battle and took to founding
titan by force
later he passed both of the titan powers
that he possessed onto his son
aaron aaron is of course the main
character of the entire story
so everybody knows his backstory but
just for a quick recap
aaron is the son of grisha and carla and
ever since he was a kid he always
dreamed about venturing beyond the walls
exploring the outside world and
experiencing true freedom when he was
only 9 years old he accompanied his
father to the home of the ackermann
family
they arrived right after the family was
attacked by kidnappers
and although the mother and father were
killed aaron managed to save the
daughter called mikasa by killing two of
the kidnappers
mikasa then took down the third
kidnapper and after this ordeal grisha
and carla took mikasa in
and effectively adopted her from that
day forward mika saneron became
practically inseparable and together
with their friend armin they eventually
witnessed the attack on shiganchina by
the colossal
and armored titan after seeing dina
fritz's mindless titan
eating his own mother before his very
eyes
aaron vowed to destroy all the titans
and eventually he
armand and mikasa joined the survey
corps at some point
after the fall of walmaria grisha gave
aaron the key to their basement
and then he forced his son to inherit
the founding and attack titan powers
at first aaron had no memory of this
even happening
and this made his first titan
transformation quite the surprise for
everyone involved
especially aaron in time aaron would of
course take possession of a third titan
power
the warhammer titan okay now let's talk
about the titan shifters who destroyed
wall maria
and upended aaron's entire life first up
we have bertolt hoover
an aldian born inside the liberio
internment zone who joined the warrior
candidate program
and was eventually chosen to inherit the
colossal titan power
bertolt was a talented warrior candidate
who quickly got the hang of using the
colossal titan
however despite his natural talent his
weak will and lack of initiative made
him dependent
on others during their training and
their mission to paradise
bertolt formed a close friendship with
reiner and bertolt would depend on
reiner's leadership for the remainder of
his life
bertolt also developed romantic feelings
for fellow marland warrior
annie leonhardt let's quickly talk about
the only
other colossal titan shifter arm and
arlert
before moving on to reiner and his
armored titan
armin attained the colossal titan power
after his mindless titan devoured
bertolt during the return to shiganshina
arc
armin was born inside the shiganchina
district just like aaron
and he was raised by his grandfather
after both of his parents were killed by
the government
they were killed for attempting to
venture beyond the walls
using a homemade hot air balloon armin
was often bullied as a child
but eventually he became close friends
with aaron and mikasa
and his new friends helped protect him
from the bullies
armin's grandfather possessed a secret
book
that talked about the outside world and
this book inspired armin to want to
venture beyond the walls
and explore the wider world which is a
goal that he shared with aaron
after witnessing the fall of walmaria
together with aaron and mikasa
all three of them decided to enlist in
the military and they ended up joining
the survey corps together
armin is not known for his physical
strength or fighting prowess
but he possesses exceptional
intelligence and has a gift for
strategic
planning which is why he was ultimately
chosen to inherit
the colossal titan power okay now let's
get to reiner who is the only known
armored titan shifter reiner is also an
ldn who was born in liberio but there is
one aspect to his backstory that makes
him different from the other marland
warriors
while reiner's mother is an aldian woman
named karina brown
his father is actually a marleian man
since romantic relationships between
marlene's and aldians are forbidden
reiner's father didn't want anything to
do with either reiner
or his mother as a young man reiner was
desperately hoping to become a marland
warrior
because that would grant honorary
marlian status for him
and his mother reiner thought that if he
and his mother could become
honorary marlins then his father would
accept them
and they could be a family unfortunately
for reiner
even after he became the new armored
titan his father rejected him as nothing
more than an
aldean devil reiner was perhaps the
weakest
overall warrior candidate in his class
and the only category in which reiner
excelled was
ideology basically reiner had completely
accepted marlene propaganda about
eldians
and he was by far the most zealous
believer in marleigh's official ideology
out of all the other warrior candidates
but even though reiner wasn't supposed
to be chosen as one of the next warriors
marcel galliard who was reiner senior
convinced the army to choose reiner
instead of his own brother porco marcel
did not want his brother to become a
titan shifter and have to go through
horrible hardships
only to die 13 years later so he
secretly ensured
that reiner would take his brother's
place
so at age 12 reiner bertolt annie and
marcel were sent to the island of
paradise with the intention of gathering
intel about the founding titan with
their ultimate goal being to capture
the founding titan and bring that power
back to marley
once they arrived on the island marcel
revealed the truth to reiner
he wasn't supposed to be chosen as the
next armored titan
he was only chosen because marcel rigged
the system
in reiner's favor then as a mindless
titan suddenly appeared and was about to
eat reiner
marcel intervened and sacrificed his own
life in order to save
reiners reiner bertolt and annie escaped
but they were now leaderless
as the most senior member of their group
marcel had just been eaten by a titan
at this point annie and bertolt wanted
to abandon the mission completely
and just return to marley but reiner
insisted
that they had to continue after getting
rejected by his father again
and after just being told that he wasn't
actually good enough to be chosen as the
armored titan
reiner was desperate to become the hero
that he and his mother
wanted him to be reiner knew that if
they abandoned the mission now
then fulfilling his dream of becoming a
hero and being accepted by marland
society
would be impossible so he convinced
annie and bertolt to continue the
mission
and he did his best to fill in the
leadership void that marcel had left
behind by intentionally
emulating many of marcel's
characteristics if you want to learn
more about reiner and his entire life
story
i did an entire video on his life and
character development
so if you want to check that out link
will be in the description
next up let's talk about annie leonhardt
the only known
female titan shifter annie was of course
part of the same warrior generation as
reiner and bertolt and she accompanied
the two of them
and marcel on the mission to parodies
annie was orphaned as a baby
and she was adopted by a single father
known only as
mr leonhardt throughout her childhood mr
leonhardt
taught annie to be a fighter and he
trained her relentlessly
in the hopes that she would one day
become a warrior candidate
he wanted annie to become a warrior
because that would improve his own life
since he would then become an honorary
merlin
thanks to annie after annie became the
female titan and was about to be sent
on the mission to parodies mr leonhardt
came to regret his selfishness
he told annie to forget about honorary
merlin's status and everything else and
just focus on staying alive and coming
home to him again
annie promised that she would and
keeping this promise has been one of her
primary motivators throughout the entire
story
it is also worth mentioning that annie
never bought into marlei's propaganda
about ldns
and the need to destroy the island
devils as a pragmatist and a realist
she was always suspicious of the merlin
government and their propaganda
unlike reiner annie's motivation was
never to become some marlene hero
or some savior of marley she just wanted
to survive
and come home to her father now let's
talk about
all four known jaw titan shifters
starting with
marcel and yeah there's a pretty big
turnover rate when it comes to the jaw
titan marcel and his younger brother
porco
both joined the warrior candidate
program at a young
age marcel inherited the jaw titan power
and his brother porco was on track to
inheriting the
armored titan but marcel did not want
his brother to become a titan shifter
and be condemned to die
young so behind his brother's back he
told his superiors that reiner should be
chosen as the next armored titan
instead of porco marcel felt guilty
about this
and so when he arrived on paradise along
with reiner bertolten annie
he told reiner the truth and when reiner
was about to be eaten by a mindless
titan
marcel felt responsible for protecting
reiner
after all if not for marcel's direct
intervention
reiner would never have even been in
this situation
so marcel decided to save reiner while
giving up his own life
in the process that mindless titan who
consumed marcel and became the next jaw
titan shifter
was of course emir not emir fritz but
the emir who would eventually become a
member of the 104th
training corps emir was an ldn girl born
in marley
around 75 years before the beginning of
the main attack on titan story
she was a homeless and nameless beggar
on the streets of marley
until she was taken in by an aldian man
who named her emir
after the progenitor emir fritz the man
then started up a cult around the mirror
claiming that this emir was some sort of
reincarnation of the ancient
eldian goddess emir fritz emir went
along with this charade because she
liked that everyone in the cult was nice
to her and treated her like a goddess
and she also liked that worshiping her
seemed to bring some happiness and hope
to these oppressed and unfortunate
people but this aldean cult was
eventually discovered by the marlene
authorities
and when that happened the man who had
taken amir in
betrayed her he claimed that the cult
was all her idea
and that she was the one who tricked him
emir did not deny the charges against
her
and she was subsequently arrested
paraded around the city streets as the
people jeered at her and pelted her with
stones
and then eventually she was taken to
parody's island and turned
into a mindless titan emir spent the
next
60 years wandering around the island as
a titan until the year
845 when reiner berthold annie and
marcel
accidentally wandered too close to her
titan as the mirror's titan was
activated by the presence of these
people
it was about to devour reiner but as
stated earlier
marcel pushed him out of the way and the
titan consumed marcel
instead some time later emir's human
form was finally restored as she
inherited marcel's jaw titan power
once she was human again emir found her
way inside the walls and assimilated
herself
into the society of parodies after
overhearing an ominous conversation
about an illegitimate child of the royal
family who was using the alias
crystallines
emir enlisted in the 104th training
corps with the intention of finding
krista
and protecting her from the people who
wanted to do her harm
now back to the previously mentioned
porco galliard
the younger brother of marcel during
their initial warrior candidate
training porco had an adversarial
relationship with reiner
porco thought that reiner was the worst
warrior candidate
and that his only strength was the fact
that he was an ideological zealot
obsessed with marlene propaganda
porco was the one who was about to
inherit the armored titan before his
brother marcel intervened to make sure
reiner gets the power
unfortunately for marcel porco still
ended up becoming a
titan shifter once emir decided to
willingly return to marley
in an attempt to protect historia she
was fed
to porco and so instead of becoming the
armored titan
porco became the jaw titan the fourth
and final jaw titan is falco grice
a 12 year old eldian boy born in liberio
he is a member of the current generation
of warrior candidates along with gabby
brown
like marcel and annie before him falco
is able to see
through marlene propaganda and he
realizes that becoming a titan shifter
is more of a curse than a blessing but
falco has strong feelings for fellow
warrior candidate
gabby and after some prodding from
reiner falco decided that he must become
the next armored titan
instead of gabby so that gabby can avoid
the curse of emir and live a full life
falco was never planning on becoming the
jaw titan but after accidentally
drinking some of zeke's spinal fluid and
then being turned into a mindless titan
by zeke
falco ended up devouring an injured
porco
and inheriting the jaw titan power from
him falco's jaw titan eventually becomes
the first
known flying titan if you're wondering
why a
jaw titan would have the ability to fly
you can check out my detailed video on
falco's flying jaw titan
link in the description okay now let's
talk about the two known
beast titans starting with zeke yeager
as mentioned earlier
zeke is the son of grisha and dina and
he has
royal blood he was born in liberio and
pressured to join the warrior candidate
program by his parents
who were dedicated eldian
restorationists they believe that if
their son could inherit one of the
shifters
his royal blood would make him an
exceptionally strong
titan and this would then allow him to
one day recapture the founding titan and
use it to restore
the aldean empire zeke was highly
intelligent
from a very young age and he quickly
realized that the restorationists
days were numbered because the marlins
were hot on their trail
believing that the destruction of the
restorationist was inevitable
zeke decided to betray his parents to
the marlins in order to save his own
life
and the lives of his grandparents zeke's
decision to betray his parents was also
influenced by the previous beast titan
tom zaver who was an important mentor
for zeke
during his time as a young warrior
candidate tom zaver also helped zeke
formulate a plan to capture the founding
titan and put an end to the suffering of
eldians
once and for all and speaking of tom
saver
he was an aldian from liberio who fell
in love with a marlene woman
because romantic relationships between
aldians and milan's were forbidden
tom hid his ldn armband whenever he was
around the woman he loved
and he concealed his eldean ethnicity
from her
the two were eventually married and had
a child together
but years later when the wife finally
found out that tom was actually an
aldian
she was so distraught that she married a
so-called elden devil
that she killed both herself and their
son
this shocking turn of events devastated
tom and he eventually came to the
conclusion that the world would be
better off if the aldians didn't
exist tom then joined up with the
warrior unit
became the beast titan and immersed
himself in titan research
while observing the next generation of
warrior candidates
tom took a liking to zeke and formed a
close relationship with him
tom would ultimately advise zeke to turn
his parents into the marlene authorities
in order to save himself and his
grandparents from certain doom
since the leaders of the restorationists
were about to be discovered anyway
turning his parents in proved zeke's
loyalty to marlei
and saved his life now let's talk about
peak finger
the only known cart titan shifter
pique is another eldian from liberio and
she lost her mother at a young
age on top of that her father was ill
and desperately needed medical care
in order to save her father's life pique
joined the warrior program
inherited the card titan power and
became an honorary merlin
which allowed her father to finally get
the medical treatment he needed
however pique noticed that her father
was saddened by the fact that she
decided to severely shorten her own life
in order to prolong his peak's ultimate
goal is to free the aldian people in the
barrio and the rest of marley
from oppression before her 13-year term
as the card titan runs out
during the mission to paradise pique was
initially kept back in marley along with
zeke
but she later joined zeke on the island
in a supporting role
and finally we have the only known
warhammer titan shifter
before that power was consumed by aaron
i am of course talking about lara tiber
the younger sister
of willie tiber we don't know much about
lara other than the fact that she is a
member of the tibers
a family of alien nobles who plotted
with king carl fritz to put an end to
the alden empire on the continent
the tibers have had the warhammer titan
in their possession for many generations
and they receive special treatment in
marlei when compared to the other
eldians the tibers are respected as
national heroes for turning against
eldia and supporting marlet
and as such they are allowed to live in
peace outside of the aldian internment
zones
the tibers are not subject to any of the
oppressive laws that apply to the other
aldeans in marlei
in fact it is strongly implied that the
tiber family actually controls the
nation of marley from behind the scenes
as the head of the tiber family willie
tiber had led everyone to believe that
he was the warhammer titan shifter but
the real warhammer titan was actually
his sister
lara and that is it the backstory of
every known titan shifter in the attack
on titan story
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like it
including videos about the unique powers
of all of the titan shifters
check out our extensive and growing
attack on titan playlist
link in the description if you want to
support
this channel and more content on the
channel leave a like
on this video and don't forget to
subscribe
this video was a ton of work so it would
really mean a lot to me if you took the
time to leave a like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
shout out to 414 anime for helping me
out
with this massive video the link to his
anime channel is down in the description
so
show him some love a big thank you to
all of our anime outpour patrons for
making videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata the world
a quiet respect pate heffa liam thompson
algertol dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life tinel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise
anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kaylafond
rathune de ora alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water the red-haired raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted no ted deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you